la cgt finira-t-elle par avoir la peau
de la loi de travail
je vous répondrai cher de forme de votre
question parce qu'avoir la peau est ce
qu'on est aujourd'hui connue
gouvernement uniquement nubile et par
l'idée d'avoir la peau de quelqu'un ou
de sauver sa propre peau quand on est en
responsabilité au gouvernement de voir
cette faire en sorte que les conditions
économiques les conditions budgétaires
les conditions sociales permettent au
pays de progresser
il s'agit pas d'avoir la peau de l'un la
peau de l'autre
je crois qu'il faisait pour vos à
l'ambition qu'elle venait de rappeler
ray une forme d'apaisement dans le débat
le débat et a eu lieu l'été vif
il a même eu lieu un peu à l'assemblée
sont orange entend dire que le 49-3
cours est interrompue
empêcher toute forme de débat ira
travaux en commissions et début de
travaux dans l'hémicycle qui s'est trop
reprendre il va entreprendre au sénat
que suite à l'assemblée et des
discussions il ya eu des amodiations de
la loi des aménagements de la loi
certains disent qu'on a vidé la loi de
sa substance d'autres disent mais non ça
reste une loi extrêmement pénalisante
j'allais dire c'est peut-être aussi le
signe qu'on est dans une espèce de
l'équipe mais leur l'apaisement
l'apaisement vous appeler à l'apaisement
que peut faire le gouvernement ou des je
pense d'abord que il faut que les
organisations syndicales dont la cgt
mais pas que la cgt
prenons nos responsabilités la
responsabilité c'est qu'au moment où au
moment où la croissance s'améliorent ce
que confirme aujourd'hui le fmi le fmi
vient vient effectivement de relever sa
prévision de croissance
il était à part nous nous avons posé
comme hypothèse 1.5 pour deux externes
alors aujourd'hui le fait me dit oui on
aura une croissance en france le prêt de
conflagration elle dit qu'elle prend ses
responsabilités en bloquant mais
justement je pense qu'au moment où la
croissance reprend de façon plutôt
significative pour espérer mieux
c'est un mauvais coup qui peut être
porté à l'économie
des journées grève des journées de
frilosité dans le monde du travail dans
les déplacements
cette comédie conditionnel ça ne l'est
déjà un mauvais goût oui donc il est
temps d'en sortir et vous l'avez déjà
chiffré ce mauvais coup pour l'économie
ou non non mais pour l'instant il est
bien sûr trop tôt pour en parler mais
vous savez que tous les élus tous les
événements qui se passent en france
aussi un retentissement sur
l'attractivité de notre pays que ce soit
en matière économique soit en matière
touristique et je pense qu'il est temps
maintenant d'en sortir mais c'est pas du
tout la voie qu'emprunte la cgt vous
avez vu la multiplication des blocages
l'appelle maintenant on aime à la grève
reconductible à la sncf à la fin du mois
oui une forme un peu de dispersion en
lançant un mouvement reconductible à la
sncf on annonce une grève à la ratp
on a fait blocage sans les raffineries
dans les dépôts de carburant je crois
qu'il ya là une attitude que les
français d'ailleurs commencé un petit
peu avant de recevoir vous attendez une
condamnation des français ceux qui se
lèvent le matin concours à une équipe
pari sur l'avenir pour reprendre les
expressions des manuels macro non
évitons les mots qui blessent les mots
qui vexe phase de mise au monde un avion
prise en otage je n'aime pas ce
vocabulaire
je n'aime pas sous quelle heure il
s'agit que chacun dans une situation qui
est difficile c'est sûr économique et
social qui est tendu vous l'avez dit il
s'agit un moment donné de dire que t'es
rock me remets ton ce pays en marche
c'est ce que nous faisons avec
responsabilité ont en posant sa nombre
de principes dans la loi qui peuvent
changer l'état d'esprit qui peuvent
parfois interpellé ont souvent été mal
présentée d'ailleurs souvent caricaturée
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont en
train d'en prendre conscience et vous
aviez en face de voir plutôt que moi
philippe martinez le leader de la cgt
que lui diriez vous je lui dirai que il
ya eu des évolutions qu'il a
probablement lui un peu trop vite les
propositions qui sont contenues dans le
projet de loi et qu'il est temps
maintenant que de sortir par le haut de
cette difficulté parce que sinon il ya
un risque économique effectivement
50 d'économies va mal c'est finalement
un risque social qui se concrétise et
des difficultés souvent pour les gens
les plus mauvais il ya des blocages qui
pénalise l'économie ou où la vie des
gens mais il ya aussi des formes de
violence qui sont nés ce qu'il ya une
forme de rupture si on élargit entre la
cgt aujourd'hui du pacte entre la cgt et
le pays
pas sûr que la cgt signe un pacte avec
le pays en passant par une signature et
patras et la cgt n'est quand même pas le
seul la seule organisation syndicale de
ce pays un surnom d' organisations
syndicales qui se sont inscrits dans des
démarches différentes de ceux de la cgt
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une nouvelle
baisse d'impôts en 2017 après celle de
2015 2016 alors que vous pouvez nous
l'annoncer c'est faisable besoin
l'oracle de verser le président de la
république a été très clair
présent dans le public a dit nous
verrons en fonction des marges qui
seront devant nous quels seront les
possibilités pour avoir des baisses
d'impôts l'année prochaine nous
souhaitons ces baisses d'impôt nous
avons commencé vous avez eu la
gentillesse l'objectivité de rappeler
qu'effectivement ça a été le cas en 2015
les prélèvements obligatoires dire
l'ensemble de ce que le l'état en tous
cas les collectivités publiques donnant
comme contribution ont baissé en trois
langues blanc les champions d'europe 1
oui m'enfin sont baissées or associés
champion d'europe sur un certain nombre
de prestations que l'on fournit à nos
concitoyens ont reparlé de la santé on
peut parler de la retraite c'est un mec
mais la peau l'impôt sur le revenu
puisque vous en parlez c'est le moment
des déclarations d'impôts les français
effectivement sont concernés sur l'impôt
qu'il est et touche plus mais c'est pas
c'est pas d'ailleurs le plus important
pour le pays nous sommes maintenant fin
du mois de mai d'une année budgétaire
aujourd'hui comment voulez-vous alors
même que les français sont seulement en
train de remplir leur déclaration
d'impôts que je sache que nous sachions
à bercy avec nos équipes
combien les recettes de l'état vont être
pour cette année en cours une année qui
est à peine commencée les recettes de
tva c'est l'engrenage ou parce que sur
un précédent d'annoncer des baisses
d'impôts donc vous parce que nous avions
deux réticents mais non je suis prudent
on peut pas entendre nos prévisions de
croissance confirmée par la loi n 2000
l'année dernière à la même époque
conduisez votre prophète prévisions de
croissance ne sera pas atteinte il va
vous manquer 10 milliards de recettes
à la fin de l'année il a manqué 0
milliards de recettes elles ont été
conformes à nos prévisions sont plus
optimistes que le président de la
république
n'a pas clairement indiquer clairement
indiqué nous en sommes s'expliquer avec
lui michel sapin et moi entre autres
avec le premier ministre a clairement
indiqué que nous ferons le point en fin
du mois de juin au début du mois de
juillet lorsque nous aurons affiner nos
prévisions de recettes pour cette année
et qu'en fonction effectivement des
tendances qui seront confirmées ou
infirmées en fonction de l'évolution de
nos recettes en fonction des taux
d'intérêt en fonction de la croissance
qui sera constaté aujourd'hui on connaît
les résultats du premier trimestre et
encore certains du 14 juillet je sais
pas s'il sera le 14 juillet le 13 ou le
haut
au début du mois de septembre la loi de
finances sera présenté au conseil des
ministres
comme tous les ans à la fin du mois de
septembre mais ça va quand même le
dernier mercer général
écoutez si les marges apparaissent se
confirme et peuvent se quantifier on
verra sous quelle forme
est ce que ça veut dire que les
différentes les nouvelles dépenses que
vous avez annoncé depuis janvier qui
sont intervenus comme comme des
sénateurs très très très rapidement
après le vote de la loi de finances
rectificative de fin d'année
est ce que ça veut dire qu'elles ont été
tellement importante que finalement la
fameuse redistribution par le françois
hollande depuis un an ou deux et déjà
fait qu'enfin une certaine manière et
que finalement ce n'est plus par l'impôt
que vous allez la poursuivre pour suivre
éventuellement mais ce que ce que vous
oubliez les uns les autres c'est que des
baisses d'impôts par exemple pour les
entreprises elles ont déjà eu lieu là le
1er avril les cotisations sociales tout
le monde l'a oublié des cotisations
sociales des employeurs ont baissé de
propos près de 4 milliards d'euros et le
chef de l'état libyen après les
entreprises les ménages mais les mines
il ya eu des mesures en faveur des
ménages on les a clairement rappelé mais
aujourd'hui nous avons annoncé 4
milliards effectivement de dépenses
supplémentaires
fallait-il ne pas les peler les mettre
en oeuvre ces mesures
fallait-il ne pas répondre à la crise
agricole avec près de 900 millions
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires sur
des réductions de cotisations aux
agriculteurs fallait il ne pas mettre en
oeuvre la prime à l embauche qui marche
bien
le plan de formation qui va nous coûter
avec la prime à l'embauché autour de 2
milliards $ et il n'a pas besoin d'un
ailier ne parut comme l'électorat lister
les sont ceux qui contestent ces mesures
va porter la critique les le point
d'indicé a été bloqué pendant cinq ans
cinq ans c'est beaucoup d'efforts qui
était demandé un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires même si nous avons pas le
regarder la campagne l'ancienne langue
d'origine
des mesures demandées au ministère sans
supprimer des fonctionnaires une baisse
des effectifs de 2 % c'est aussi la
conséquence de l'augmentation du poids
nan il c'est pas nouveau ça veut dire
nous nous avons une stabilité globale
nous avions une stabilité globale de nos
effectifs durant les trois premières
années de la législature avec une
augmentation des enseignants une eau du
nombre d'enseignants avec une
augmentation du nombre de policiers avec
une augmentation du nombre de personnels
de la justice
nous avons donc baisser nos
fonctionnaires dans un salon de services
à bercy dans service des finances
publiques nous supprimions environ 2000
postes tous les ans la masse salariale
des fonctionnaires n'y a pas eu une
baisse de la masse à la remontée de 0 9%
jaunards au passage que ces chiffres le
plus faible depuis des années à
l'augmenter traditionnellement de 1 25%
elle n'a augmenté si j'ose dire que de 0
9%
donc il ya eu une maîtrise en tout cas
même c'est pas une baisse de la masse
salariale
parce qu'il ya quand même la promotion
et les fonctionnaires qui conduisent
naturellement même si points à 10 est
gelée à une augmentation de revenus
donc ces 4 milliards c'est ce que nous
avions fait l'année dernière année
dernière en cours d'année on a vu des
mesures sur la sécurité on avait des
mérites mais l'opposition de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
conteste ce chiffre et parle de plus
notre plutôt de 6 milliards sinon ça il
a reconnu que ses troupes et gt gt la
commission des finances il ajoute des
dépenses de 2016 à des dépenses de 2017
je reviens à la baisse d'impôts parce
qu'en fait vous êtes coincé par le chef
de l'état il a annoncé qu'il y aurait
est ce que j'ai l'air de quoi écouter
le chef d'état a partout il annonce
héricourt en tout cas mes pairs vous
avez la présidence je suis moi je moi
j'essaie mission à une mission et puis
cette impression c'est de réduire les
déficits il ya deux moyens de réduire
les déficits c'est d'augmenter les
recettes par des augmentations d'impôts
il n'en est pas question
attention une stratégie réduction des
impôts nous l'avons déjà fait et nous
continuerons à le faire mais si nous
n'arrivons pas à contenir les dépenses
de façon suffisante
on ne pourra pas réduire les impôts et
réduire le déficit en même temps mais
j'observe c'est très important qu'en
2015 c'est ce que nous avons fait en
2015 nous avons réduit le déficit public
et nous avons réduit les prélèvements
obligatoires donc les impôts
une question sur les pressions sur
google qui est soupçonné de fraude
fraude fiscale également en france il
une perquisition du siège parisien ce
matin du géant américain
on sait que ça fait suite à une plainte
de l'administration fiscale
est ce que le bras de fer se durcit avec
avec google par le biais de la justice
alors je vous remercie beaucoup de me
poser cette question le bras de fer il a
toujours été dur contrairement à ce qui
dit parfois où ce que certains peuvent
penser légitimement nous sommes un strap
je suis astreint au secret fiscal
donc je ne peux pas aujourd'hui vous
dire combien les cas elle dans quel
délai voyez quand même on sait que
google ait menacé le redressement d'un
milliard trois cents millions c'est vous
qui le dites c'est moi qui ai dit vous
qui le dites s'est pas démentie par dont
on sait que c'est ça que je ne peux pas
vous démentir je vous donne un exemple à
l'offre cinq entreprises multinationales
l'année dernière en 2015 ont fait
l'objet redressements fiscaux et de
pénalités pour 3,3 milliards d'euros à
cinq et à 5 seulement nous avons
redressé 3,3 milliards d'euros de
d'impôts et de pénalités
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ce
gouvernement
et c'est pour le moins une nouveauté est
un gouvernement qui travaille sur les
questions de fiscalité qui poursuit à ce
nombre d'entreprises nous ne faisons pas
de publicité aujourd'hui c'est le
parquet national et financier mais vous
avez vous avez rappelé que c'était sur
la planche oui
sur la base des plaintes d'ailleurs de
la direction chez dans une ville à la
justice màj cela fait 9 ans sont invités
dans cette perte est jamais vous recevez
en tant que ministre est ce que vous
seriez prêt à une transaction en or
google
non il n'ya pas de transactions dans ce
pays nous avons été sollicité plusieurs
fois et que ça s'est passé en bretagne
me vis à ses patients de retraités et
vous avez vu qu'elle a été le montant
des bonus moins que la somme sp d'entre
elles âgées vers l'hôtel en sarre
en tout cas c'est le fisc aujourd'hui
qui a notifié le redressement
si google souhaite google et d'autres
souhaitent aller au bout des procédures
ils iront au bout des procédures mais
nous ne ferons pas de transactions sur
ce type de situation
qu'est ce que j'ai dit qu'est ce que je
maintiens sur la situation financière
des collectivités territoriales les
dotations de l'état représentent un
quart des recettes des collectivités
territoriales ce car nous l'avons baissé
de 8%
oui 2 poids 2 je vous avais ces
présentations collectivités oui pour ça
représente pour le quart de leurs
recettes
une baisse significative 3 66 milliards
environ mais ça mais le reste
le reste des recettes des collectivités
territoriales le recettes fiscales que
ce soit les impôts locaux que ce soit la
cvae pardon de l'enseignement technique
oui mais enfin ce sont des impôts que
paye toutes les entreprises la
contribution foncière des entreprises
tous les enfants une mutation et droit
d'injonction d'en face à mantes et ont
augmenté sans variation des taux de fac
de façon considérable pourquoi tout
simplement parce que les bases sont
révisés tous les ans pour certaines
d'entre elles et pour d'autres notamment
les dm théo les droits de mutation comme
vous l'évoquez mais de questionner
augmente et va le marché immobilier
s'est décoincé et donc quand on regarde
l'ensemble de la recette à n'ont pas
baissé
elles ont augmenté de 1 70% pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
pris ce que vous avez dit c'est à dire
que les mesures que vous avez mis en
place et cette baisse des dotations
pourri ce qu'ils vous disent aujourd'hui
c'est une provocation on ne vous croit
pas ce que parce que ils ont été
habitués à une situation beaucoup plus
confortable est ce que vous croyez que
c'est facile pour l'état de réunir les
ministres et de leur demander des
efforts de réduction de leurs effectifs
de leurs moyens et qu'ils ont été dans
l'ordre habituel avant quand je pense
que mentalement j'étais élu local qui
dirait que j'ai été élu local je crois
connaître un peu cette situation j'étais
du régional
aussi il y a trois raisons pour
lesquelles l'investissement si je ne
conteste pas je lui ai dit d'ailleurs
lui-même écrit est en péril non il est
pas en péril il a baissé alors ils
baissent systématiquement lorsqu'il ya
des renouvellements électoraux ce qui
était le cas généralement une baisse de
l'ordre de 8%
il a baissé de lampes de 11% c'est plus
que d'habitude c'est vrai plus que
d'habitude aussi parce que les équipes
ont quand même plus changer que
d'habitude
en termes d'orientation politique
deuxième raison l'incertitude sur un
salon de textes qui sont venus à être
mis en oeuvre tardivement et nous avons
au gouvernement notre part de
responsabilité la fusion des régions a
mis du temps à se faire
la carte des intercommunalités qui vient
d'être arrêté au 31 mars a mis du temps
à se faire
ça veut dire que des collectivités des
communes des intercommunalités qui ne
savait pas dans quelle configuration se
retrouverait le lendemain avec quelles
compétences ont retardé vous l'aurez
aujourd'hui maintenant ça suffit vous
investissez non je le redis aujourd'hui
regardez les collectivités locales
encore un chiffre des pauses
traditionnellement trésor 30 milliards
d'euros en fin d'année l'année dernière
c'était 34
c'est à dire 4 milliards de plus que la
veille mais contre tous contre tous les
élus de france de droite de gauche
alors alain comment expliquer ce
phénomène inédit vont chauffer sévère
d'abord je ne crois pas être seul un pan
de deux collègues y compris au
gouvernement qui partagent cette analyse
moi c'est une analyse que je donne mais
si vous voulez baisser la dépense
publique vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure que nous étions les champions
d'europe de la dépense publique mais
c'est pas qu'elle vise à éviter que les
dépenses des collectivités territoriales
sont supérieures aux dépenses de l'état
il faut l'avoir en tête ou à peu près en
tout cas équivalente
donc on peut pas imaginer baisser la
dépense publique
si on ne baisse pas la dépense des
collectivités territoriales et elle a
moins augmenté que d'habitude d'ailleurs
c'est un premier résultat
donc si je suis prêt à la confrontation
à la confrontation vous êtes prêt à la
confrontation qui revient avec monsieur
je suis pas l'habitude de faire
vous allez y aller au congrès des maires
non parce que je suçais par engage non
mais j y en a qui va y aller c'est le
président de la récup justement le mot
ce qui peut éviter la bronca des publics
qui sera sur place
qu'est ce qu'il doit faire pour éviter
cette branche généralement quand on rend
visite à quelqu'un on arrive avec des
fleurs cadeaux un livre un cadre où je
pense qu'encore un ado rick fera certain
nombre de d'annonce au congrès des
maires sur
la dgf la réforme de la dgf le montant
de la réduction de nos déchets si les
dotations versées par l'état il y aura
des annonces du chef de l'état bourdieu
faune et de diverses personnes de
personne ne peut penser un seul instant
que le chef de l'état n'aura pas certain
nombre de messages apportée aux mères
mais pas seulement mer les messages des
mesures oui mais enfin ce n'est les
maires ne se contente pas de parole
monsieur fillon d'y faire travailler 39
heures mais il dit pas s'il paye 39 35
heures mais qu'il le dise lui dit aux
gens qui aujourd'hui je travaille 35
heures the les traits 39 heures mais si
c'est pour le même salaire et le dit pas
je ne sais pas comment il va faire
autre élément alors c'est pas monsieur
fillon sarkozy choix qui donne un poids
de 10 % ont parlé de la baisse de
l'impôt
oui enfin il propose aussi d'imposer aux
collectivités territoriales ne pas de ne
plus embaucher au moment du départ en
retraite
comment ils purent 2d mais comment il
peut le faire
la constitution dans notre pays donne la
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre des lois du
pays
je peux voir que vous êtes toujours
aujourd'hui tout le monde est vent
debout contre une baisse des dotations
qui l'est ce qui mettrait le pays laisse
encore augmenter les recettes de des
collectivités locales vous allez leur
dire que qu'il ne remplace pas l'art
leurs fonctionnaires de façon
autoritaire
ceci c'est une politique de gribouille
et cent mille fonctionnaires à bercy
nous sommes allés ministère qui supprime
le plus emploi du moindre là par exemple
de la direction générale des finances
publiques deux mille 2000 et c'est
difficile je voulais vous montre les
lettres des maires des sénateurs des
députés
les républicains qui m'écrivent il ne
faut pas à tarbes ferme et à lagence
telle trésorerie ne faut pas à jeun il
ne faut pas à bordeaux regroupe en effet
quand elle promettait la rupture
il vous remettra lors que nous faisons
2000 suppressions d'emplois à bercy il
vous en promettent cent mille par an
mais ceux ci étaient impossibles